-I've never played
that game faster
with a more confident person
in my entire lifetime.
-I wanted more.
-No, I'll tell you
what happened.
You're just excited about
the World Cup,
'cause France won.
-Yes!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yes. France won today.
-Yeah, but you were so excited.
But you love the World Cup.
-I love the World Cup.
It's a very important time,
every four years, for my family.
-Yes. And --
But who do you root for?
You root for --
-Well, for Mexico.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course.
Until they get disqualified.
Then I go for France.
-Yeah.
-Because it's very important
to keep a good marriage.
-But can you tell me
what you were saying earlier?
'Cause there was
someone watching the game
with you at your house.
-We were watching the --
We loved the pranks.
-Yes, pranks are fun.
Yeah, they're fun.
-I think if you're Mexican,
it's in your genes.
-Oh, really?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And --
-But this is a good thing.
You can play this at home.
-Yeah. We were
all watching the game,
the Mexico game.
And there was a friend
who wanted to go to the bathroom
for a long time but didn't
want to miss anything.
-Yeah.
-And, finally, he built up --
He couldn't take it anymore.
And he went into the bathroom.
And we all waited a little bit
for him to put his pants down,
and then we all screamed,
"Goal!"
-"Goal!"
He came running out of
the bathroom.
"What's going on?!"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, of course.
-That's such a good bit.
-Yes.
-I love that. I'm gonna do that.
Well, happy holidays.
What do you do for the holidays?
Do you spend it here?
Where do you spend it?
-I do fake holidays,
because we have to have
Christmas with my family.
and then a Christmas
with François' family.
-Yeah.
-But -- And then we have our own
little family
to have a Christmas.
But I'm not Santa Claus
that can be in many places
at the same time.
-No, yeah. Yeah, he's magic.
-So we pretend,
like on the 21st or the 22nd,
that it's Christmas.
And we do it with my family.
And then we pretend again --
-You just wake up and you go,
"It's Christmas"?
-Yeah, "Oh, it's Christmas Eve."
And we do the cooking.
So, we live
Christmas three days.
-Does everyone know
that it's fake Christmas?
-Everybody knows,
but everybody's a good actor.
And the Christmas spirit --
-In your house,
it could be a prank.
You'd be like,
"Merry Chr-- Just kidding."
-You know, when it gets tricky
is in the nacimiento,
you know,
where you put the baby?
-Mm-hmm.
-Sometimes, we have
some conversations like,
"Put the baby.
"It's not Christmas."
"Just put the baby."
-Yeah. Can you explain to me
what's happening
in this photo, because --
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-That's my owl.
-Yes, I know that.
So, that's a real owl.
-That's a real owl.
-Yes.
-She loves Christmas.
She, however,
hates the World Cup.
-She does not like
the World Cup?
-No, because
she doesn't understand why
we're screaming
and the house is shaking.
You know?
She doesn't get soccer.
She loves Christmas,
the Christmas tree.
She destroys the little things.
-You're like,
"France is winning,"
and the owl's like, "Who, who?"
-Yes, exactly.
-You can take that joke.
Take it. I can't turn it off.
Can't turn it off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't stop it.
It's terrible.
Bad jokes all over my house.
But the owl -- Does the owl go
in the tree at all?
-Yes, the owl goes --
What do you mean go in the tree?
Like, go in the bathroom --
-No, not go to the bathroom.
Do you put -- Does the owl go
in, like, as an ornament?
-I actually have another owl
that is a fake owl
that is an ornament.
And I have to say --
-What happens when this owl --
-She gets really confused.
She tries to,
like, play and stuff,
but the other owl
is just really stuck-up.
Then, she starts checking
all the balls and stuff.
-Yeah.
-You know?
I have a Tour Eiffel,
she likes that one.
-She loves it.
-Yeah, she loves it.
-I love that you always
have fun like this.
-She scares everybody, though.
-The owl does?
-Yeah, because, you know --
How fun is it to scare people?
I love it. I love it.
-I do not love it.
-I love -- You don't love
scaring people?
-I do not like
anyone scaring me
and I don't like scaring anyone.
-But, Jimmy,
the anticipation of the face --
-It feels like
you're going to scare me now.
-I start laughing.
You know, I enjoy it so much.
And then --
-I just heard a noise.
-It's just imagining
the reactions.
-Stop talking about it.
I'm getting scared.
No one's getting scared tonight.
-I love it.
-No, we're going to
talk about --
We're going to talk about
"Puss in Boots."
-Yes, let's talk about
-"Puss in Boots: The Last Wish."
By the way, it's phenomenal.
-It's really good, guys.
-I loved the other ones.
This one's my favorite one.
-Sometimes, I lie to you.
I say, "Oh, it's really good.
Go see it."
No, this one's for real.
-This one's fantastic.
It has a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
96% rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
And my girls watched it,
and they were just like,
"This is the best movie ever."
-And the best part,
it's good for the entire family.
-It was funny jokes.
It was good songs.
-Yeah.
-It was great.
-Even the teenagers,
which are so hard to please,
are going to like this one.
-It got a
Critics' Choice nomination
and a Golden Globe nomination.
Congratulations.
-So far.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great cast also.
-Not bad.
Fanta-- Antonio Banderas.
-Wonderful.
-You guys together
are just fantastic.
I mean, with this,
the whole idea of this one is,
he's down to his last life.
He's -- 'Cause Puss --
-You know, cats have nine,
but he's got one left.
-Yeah. He's lived so much that
he's down to his last life.
And it's like, when that
happens, what do you do?
You've got to kind of
think about life, eh?
-Well, that's what's
wonderful about the film,
that it's really philosophical.
But it's does, like,
what the first "Shrek" did,
that the humor is for the kids,
take it one way,
the adults another way.
And this talks about a lot of
really interesting
things in life,
and the kids see it one way, but
for us, it's very interesting.
-They did
a fantastic job with it.
And you did fantastic, as well.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Salma Hayek Pinault in
"Puss in Boots: The Last Wish."
Take a look.
-Kitty,
may I please see the map?
-No.
-Seriously?!
You won't let me hold it
for even one minute?
-Nope. Not even for one second.
-Come on, Kitty.
You've got to trust me.
-Wait. W-What's going on
with his eyes?
Oh, they're getting bigger.
Oh, Kitty!
You've got to trust him.
Look at those eyes.
-Really? You call that cute?
-[ Gasps ] Oh, look at her!
[ Gasps ]
Those guys are
even bigger than yours.
Do whatever she wants, Puss.
Wait a second.
So poofy!
No! With the paws?
Come on!
[ Gasps ]
With the hat?
It's all...so...cute!
Cuteness overload!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Salma Hayek Pinault, everybody.
"Puss in Boots: The Last Wish"
is in theaters December 21st.
We'll be right back with
Wiz Khalifa. Stick around.